you mentioned so much about your
talent about
singing about being able to use your
talent to give to people joy and a part
of that talent is you know being able to
put things that are in reality into the
realm of imagination and you've done
that in philanthropy as well to be able
to lead a civil rights movement you need
pure imagination to be able to imagine a
world without this injustice
and you've mentioned a lot about
domestic issues i was wondering what is
a world that you imagine for
global citizens for people even in the
united states to be able to look beyond
their borders and to help the people in
the international sphere
i think the greatest opportunity that's
been put through modern civilization
was yet another attempt to arrive at a
forum
where there could be the council of all
nations
of all people to sit and to have the
most important thing we've experienced
as a species
and that is the right to sit in a forum
and to convince each other
of each other's
beauty of each other's choices
and to compete in that sense we used to
do it territorially walk and club
somebody over the head
take their village take their turf take
their women take their everything and in
that might and power we saw
uh the the growth of civilization
it's really something else and the
united nations for me always said wow
here's another chance with modern
technology and and how quickly we can
communicate this forum
is where we should be
having our greatest renaissance having
our greatest time and the forum still
exists in its physical design
the enemy and money and power has
constantly made it the tool of least
choice they're always saying oh the
united nations uh isn't about anything
it's just
self-serving
what does that mean
it's sure it serves itself
but we're all in the united nations to
serve self and to serve interest is to
iron out
whose interests harms who
and whose joy
is celebrated by who
it's a place in which you don't just buy
and sell each other it's not it's not a
trade it's not a trade fair
you're not going to just negotiate the
new price of wheat
it's just the human soul
human beings
and we have yet to let that humanity
emerge
the way in which it should but i think
it's survived up to now because that
humanity is tenaciously
knocking at the human door to say let us
in
let us become part of your your daily
debate
that's become part of your analysis
and i think
if i am to
make a reach here
that the next
paradigm the next real
joy on the horizon
is where
women will take this
i think
i think
there is a thing going on here that says
all this now lands
at the doorstep of the choices that
women will make
because i think
men have run out of the options for
their evil
and they only that can help us is the
generosity of the spirit of women
coming at the table and talking about
life and healing and
and all the things we
uh dismiss them for
because you have the weaker sex and all
those little things we throw around you
know
the stupidity of it but i think it's
just something we just have to make part
of our popular vocabulary
you know big deal it isn't something
there's not one thing that's going to
con this i don't think there's going to
be some miraculous
revelation from the heavens and
a voice will come forth and pronounce us
or whatever
we think we need to be
it's going to come from ant like
daily encounter
and bumping into one another creating
and growing and building
and being able to make the selection
between what that which should survive
because it's good and that which will be
left
to nurture the rest of life because it's
going to decay
that make any sense to you thank you